perte de recettes de parking et forte
diminution des activités commerciales à
versailles lakovic 19 et le confinement
ont laissé des traces
la taxe de séjour et un montant
significatif si on estime qu'ils
voulaient coco mulet on pense qu'on a
perdu à peu près 8 millions d'euros de
recettes avec les dépenses nouvelles
c'est considérable pour notre budget sur
six mois le domaine de versailles a vu
son nombre de visiteurs baissaient de
77% par rapport à 2019
c'est 60% pour le château de rambouillet
au musée d'archéologie nationale de
saint germain en laye la baisse est de
40% depuis la réouverture fin juin grâce
à l'été culturel du ministère
on est passé à une situation
relativement satisfaisant nous avons
proposé au jeune public et aux enfants
des ateliers d'expérimentation dans la
cour qui ont très bien marché
nous avons accueilli six enfants sur les
deux mois
le talon et judicaire et politique de la
ville autre secteur durement touché
celui de l'hôtellerie les nuitées en
juin ont été divisés par six par rapport
à 2010 neuf annulations de séminaires
réduction de voyages d'affaires le
remplissage n'atteint parfois que 20%
parce qu'il s'est plutôt bien passé
c'est les mois de juillet août avec un
taux de remplissage qui était quasiment
équivalent à celui des années
précédentes mais avec une baisse de prix
de 25% par rapport aux années
précédentes
14 millions de touristes en moins un
manque à gagner de 6 milliards d'euros
pour aider à la relance la région
ile-de-france créer un label de sécurité
sanitaire ce label répondra à des normes
drastiques de sécurité sanitaire il
pourra être affiché dans les bars dans
les cafés dans les hôtels dans les
musées pour prouver à tous nos clients
qu'ils soient français ou étrangers que
nous sommes une région sûre en
ile-de-france tourisme ces cinq cent
mille emplois et 7 % de la richesse sur
2020 la région estime que seulement 20
millions de touristes la visiteront en
ils étaient 50 millions